تحذيرات عربيه لاسرائيل من اقتحام باحات
الاقصى البانتاجون يحقق بقضيه تسريب
الوثائق السريه وردا على هجوم الصواريخ
اسرائيل تشن غارات على سوريا هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا
بكم
تحت اعينى وحمايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه
اقتحم عشرات المستوطنين باحات المسجد
الاقصى منذ صباح اليوم بهدف منع وصول
المصلين الفلسطينيين اليها وجرت
الاقتحامات عبر باب المغاربه وباب السلسله
في الجدار الغربي للمسجد بدورها حذرت
وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه مما وصفتها
بالتبعات الكارثيه لاستمرار اسرائيل في
خرق الوضع التاريخي والقانوني القائم في
الاقصى وانتهاكاتها لحرمه الاماكن المقدسه
خصوصا في شهر رمضان محمله في الوقت ذاته
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد
تداعيات خطيره تسبب بها تسريب وثائق
امريكيه وصفت بانها في غايه السريه
البانتاجون اعلن فتحه تحقيق شامل لتحديد
مصدر تسريب تلك الوثائق التي تفصل
استراتيجيه واشنطن وحلف الناتو لدعم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه في وجه الهجوم الروسي
كذلك علاقه كوريا الجنوبيه بتلك الحرب من
جانبها اعلنت وزاره العدل الامريكيه اجراء
تحقيق مستقل في الامر ذاته في وقت ذكرت
نيويورك تايمز ان البيت الابيض يعمل على
حذف صور تلك التقارير من على تويتر
وتليجرام مؤكده ان المعلومات الوارده في
الوثائق عمرها خمسه اسابيع على الاقل
في سوريا عدا سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي الى
اجواء البلاد بعد ان قصفت طائراته عده
اهداف عسكريه بينها مجمع تابع للفرقه
الرابعه بالاضافه الى منظومات رادارات
ومواقع مدفعيه تابعه لقوات النظام السوري
في كل من ريف دمشق والقنيطره وكاله سانا
الحكوميه قالت ان الصواريخ اطلقت من
الجولان السوري المحتل وتسببت بوقوع خسائر
ماديه من جهته اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
القصف ياتي ردا على اطلاق صواريخ من سوريا
باتجاه مرتفعات الجولان
في عالم التواصل الاجتماعي تسبب بدء تويتر
بتطبيق قرار العلامه الزرقاء بمقابل مادي
الى فوضى في علامات التوثيق خبراء تقنيون
علقوا بانه بعد تطبيق القرار متى يصعب
التفريق بين الحسابات القديمه الموثقه
لشخصيات عامه مثل باراك اوباما وحسابه
توثيق المدفوعه شهريا وبالتالي قلل القرار
من قيمه تلك العلامه شخصيات شهيره ومنهم
نجم كره السله الامريكي
كانت اعلنت انها لن تدفع اشتراكا مقابل
العلامه الزرقاء وسبقتهم بذلك صحيفه التي
شددت على انها لن تدفع سنه واحدا مقابل
هذه الخدمه
الى بريطانيا وعوده من جديد لازمه الامير
هاري وزوجته ميجا ماركل مع العائله الملكه
اذ ازاحت صحيفه
عن كتاب جديد للمراسل الملكي روبرت جوبسن
يحمل اسم ملكنا ويكشف عن غضب الامير هاري
بعد ان رفض الملك تشارلز الثالث وضع اسمه
تعود الى عام 2016 حين ابلغ الملك تشارلز
هاري بالقرار مبررا ان تكاليفهم عاليه
واوضح جبسون في كتابه هذا ان الملك توقف
عن تلقي مكالمات هاري بعد ان شتمه الاخير
وطلب مرارا الاموال من والده مشددا على
انها من حقه ومن حقي عائلته ايضا
[موسيقى]